see as the distinguishing strength in
Latin America how will this strength
growth and impact development latin
america has abundance of natural
resources that the world needs and and
this can be triggered to develop the
world needs minerals the world needs
food but Latin America needs to make
sure that it all it provides that to the
world but it also adds value and adding
value the income of that Americans will
increase and the living standards will
increase so the main strength is that
the real the reason is very rich in what
the rest of the world is lacking and
let's begin with one very important
component here which is biodiversity and
water these are abundant resources in
the region that we must preserve and we
must learn how to use well but in the
future this will be the region's
greatest strength in terms of world
competitiveness
final Latin America has one of the
highest youth unemployment rates in the
world how come Latin America increase
opportunities for young people well
Latin America does not provide enough
jobs to the youth so this is a major
problem and the reason for that is that
the region has antiquated labor laws
that prevent employment that restrict
employment and that push a lot of people
into informatika so the region has to
upgrade at labor legislation and put it
in the in the context and the level that
some of the developed world has much
more flexibility but at the same time
protection to the worker but flexibility
in terms of the ability to hire reducing
the costs because the trend is not good
too much informatica too few yobs are
being created for the youth of Latin
America